very dramatic
pump out by cb butler
swing and a miss chasing upstairs and
bushet down on strikes two away and
bobashette
almost screwed himself into the ground
he really went around
twice with that swing and the bases are
loaded right now stanton
just coming back with the night off last
night huge opportunity to throw out some
runs early
base hit to right field le mayo scores
voigt will stop at third
the throw comes all the way home it's an
rbi single for jean carlos stanton
and they have an early one-nothing lead
last we saw off torres he pinch hit got
a big two-run double
ground ball short this could be two
there's one on the first it's a double
play scoring his point
so no rbi for torres but the yankees
lead
two nothing he has feasted on the blue
jay since putting on pinstripes hitting
4-16 against toronto
anderson to le mayhew fastball on the
inside corner strike
three called a pitch that chase anderson
desperately needed and maybe got the
benefit
of a wide inside corner for the blue
jays
down two nothing to the new york yankees
having gone six up six
down to start says gurio drills a ball
deep left center field and that might
get him a promotion
he lines a home run to left center and
the blue jays are on the board
that's his first career hit against
tanaka he was over eight
and he hammered that ball that's a big
ballpark that's his ninth home run of
the season and
the blue jays are on the board early
that one's served in the left field
gardiner coming on slides
and makes the play one away now beau
bechet got runners at second and third
right back up the middle and that is
through for a base hit
jensen will score biggio will stop at
third
now bechet's going for second and is
thrown out there
a run in but bushet out trying to
stretch it to
second bisho was stopped and look at
tanaka he cut the ball himself and makes
a terrific throw to taurus
to nao bushet stanton hit a line drive
single to right his first down
that one is hammered to left field
goriel back
leaps he can't make the play and it goes
up against the wall and karen's back in
the left
and stanton will be at second with a two
out double boy hit that like a
laser there's the lead run at second
base and here's glebe torres
and he got him so anderson gets out of
it here's gary sanchez
runner goes and that one is ripped into
left field
that is going to be a base hit and up
against the wall an absolute bullet
off the bat of sanchez frazier will
score easily
it's an rbi double for gary sanchez and
the yankees take a 3-2 lead
so he picks up his 20th ribby does
sanchez and here's gardner
runner at second one out that one is
driven deep to right center field
there it goes sia into the yankee
bullpen
a two run shot for gardner and the
yankees now lead
five to two well the home runs are
coming and you've seen some glimpse
lately in the last week or so of brett
gardner starting to turn his year around
and here is dj he swings
and supply ball down the right field
line that ball is gone
over the wall boy does he have that
stroke
down inside out stroke to right field
david john makes long gone
he almost to right and he and gardner
go back to back and a belly to belly
and the yankees now take a 6-2 lead
luke voigt wraps one deep into right
center field
there it goes see ya back
to back to back 20th home run for boyt
and the yankees are pouring it on as
they lead
seven to two here's stanton and then he
swings and
it's a long drive to right center it is
high that is
far it is gone the ball went
over the grandstand and up into the
bleachers
a stantonian home run
giancarlo no si stop follow
he hits another home run yanks with four
home runs in the inning
i think they've had 17 home runs in the
last three games
well now clay per tourist has his turn
high fly ball
deep left center there it goes how about
five
see ya a home run for gleber torres
the bronx bombers are flexing 9-2
yankees
tony i don't know what you do as a
pitcher when you've given up five home
runs in an inning but i tell you one
thing
the yankees are impressive offensively
right now
remember last week in buffalo wow
have time to change
and guriel drives the ball to deep right
field and gone
his second home run of the game
so he's doing everything he can right
now it is nine to three
he's had a good series remember he had
three hits on tuesday night in the
opener of this series including a home
run
so here's gary sanchez he's one for
three an rbi double and a run scored
high fly ball left field gorielle back
reaching for the wall he's at the wall
see ya another home run for the yankees
as sanchez
goes yard and it's ten three
bombers as the blue jays are making it
interesting the time run will be on deck
so a safe situation
for chapman as he comes in and a swing
and a base hit it to center field or
left center for beshette
and two runs will come in to score the
blue jays are down to their
final out chapman's trying to stop it
and he does as
hernandez strikes out 101 miles an hour